the images of lifeless bodies and bound
hands may finally force the world to act
to show what happened to rufus
this warrants him he is a war criminal
in washington president joe biden vowed
swift new sanctions and directly called
for prosecution of vladimir putin and
his regime we have to gather the
information we have to continue to
provide ukraine with the weapons they
need to continue the fight
and we have to gather all the detail so
this could be an actual have a war crime
trial across europe more fast moves to
further isolate moscow lithuania told
the russian ambassador to leave
germany and france expelled dozens of
russian diplomats the eu vowed deeper
sanctions after seeing evidence of
atrocities we will advance as a matter
of urgency the work on further sanctions
against kremlin's murderous war
machinery yet ukraine's cries of
genocide have not compelled any country
to change its position on direct
military involvement we have to forget
about half measures
you cannot impose sanctions with your
left hand and trade with russia with
your right hand during a joint
appearance with the ukrainian foreign
minister the british foreign secretary
like many western leaders was reluctant
to put a label on russia's actions now
to the question of genocide that is a
matter for the courts to determine
but what i want to be very clear about
is the uk is taking the maximum approach
we're taking the maximum approach on
sanctions it all leaves open the
question of how far russia must go
before the west steps in
the desire for a negotiated peace may
supersede calls for rapid prosecutions
pragmatically there are people who worry
about pursuing accountability before you
have a peace settlement yet whatever
else is revealed by the russian retreat
may leave the world with no choice but
to take the kind of direct action they
have vowed to avoid
jackson prosco global news washington